[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute wieder aus unserem garten samira
und lassen jetzt gleich zu hause und
dann werden wir zusammen hier die
tomatenpflanzen als ich die reifen
tomaten ernten und ich habe ihn das
story schon gefragt möchtet ihr wissen
was ich daraus mache wie ich die
lebensmittel aus dem garten haltbar
machen und ihr habt alle vorjahr
gestimmt heute geht es also um das thema
tomaten wie kann ich sie für den winter
haltbar machen was kann ich denn
überhaupt alles draus machen muss sich
die tomaten verschenken oder kann ich
damit meine vorratskammer film heute
gibt es also ein paar tipps und tricks
rund um tomaten
ketchup nehme ich jetzt noch bisschen
sellerie mit und ich brauche noch äpfel
denn ein ketchup mache ich mit zucker
und ein ketchup mache ich mit äpfeln da
war praktisch ein zuckerfreies kitsch ob
das reicht
die äpfel diesem schön süß ist meine
sorte steht nicht tragen ein paar stück
aber ist ein leckerer ab
die mädels waren jetzt richtig fleißig
wenn man ganz viel im garten geerntet
und ich zeige euch jetzt in diesem video
wie ich die tomaten halt mache und
welche leckeren rezepte daraus entstehen
werden kommt mit in die küche
ich glaube die leckerste variante
tomaten zu verarbeiten zumindest für
kinder ist der job deswegen machen wir
jetzt ketchup auf jeden fall selber ihr
braucht dafür wirklich nur ganz wenige
zutaten
ich brauche jetzt für meinen ketchup aus
automaten aus dem garten noch bisschen
sellerie und manche nehmen ja zucker und
gerade in gekauft um catcher bis er
wirklich ganz viel zucker enthalten
deswegen gibt es bei uns gar nicht außer
der morath holt sich das mal elan im den
lieber einen hocker und deswegen gibt es
heute eine variante einmal ganz
klassisch mit zucker aber viel weniger
zucker als eingekauft ohne job und
einmal mit einem apfel das heißt
komplett ohne zucker zeigt euch mal die
zutaten für das ketchup brauche ich
tomaten ich nehme eine zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe etwas sellerie aus dem
garten die habe ich es ich schäfer
senfkörner salz einer prise nelken und
für die eine variante nämlich braunen
zucker und für die anderen nämlich den
apfel
ja also ich leider machen wir jetzt
variante eins mit zucker du darfst in
braun und sogar nehmen alles kommt jetzt
in einen topf das heißt es wird nichts
vorher angebraten und legst du denn hin
schön alle gewürze ein denn essig ryan
und ich kann jetzt schon mal alles
andere schneiden
pfeffer der essig riecht so eklig nicht
sellerie das richtfest
du willst nicht riechen wie bericht
nicht so gut aber ich erinnere mich an
meine kindheit da waren wir auch aber so
dass sie irgendwo bei der tante brenner
entfernten verwandten und weiter heraus
immer nach gemüsebrühe und ich habe es
gehasst dorthin zu gehen ja nicht der
hochsteigen ich gebe ihnen apfel marke
kurz ich hab noch im zweiten apfel den
gebe ich dir den habe ich jetzt nämlich
der hat die perfekte größe nämlich für
das ketchup mayo ketchup samira macht
das thema gar nicht aber die latina
so knoblauch sehen noch schön fein
schneiden
also im prinzip einfach alle
gemüsesorten kleinschneiden vorsichtig
da kann man mal komm mit dem messer und
dann alles in den topf geben und dann
wird es nämlich gekocht und man muss
wirklich sonst nichts tun erst mal
richtig den hexenkessel nicht jetzt
besser aber gleich wenn die tomaten
kommen
vorsichtig so auch die zunge ab auch
fein schneiden
ja du darfst sie dann reinmachen okay
so aber gehen jetzt rüber zum herbst und
da kommt jetzt das ketchup drauf wird
gleich gekocht und dann muss es für etwa
30 minuten lang kochen immer mal wieder
rühren denn hätte natürlich auch
unterstellen damit der geschmack sich
voll entfalten kann und die tomaten
natürlich auch weich werden und das
gleiche machen wir jetzt hier nochmal
mit dem abfall ja dann kannst du essen
das ketscher besitzt fertig gekocht ich
kann sie jetzt einmal pürieren
und dann streiche ich durch das fleißige
lieschen ihr könnt auch die flotte lotte
nehmen oder einfach ein hase und so
bekomme ich einfach jetzt noch die
großen teile raus und es wird ein
richtig schönes feines ketchup
die reste auf keinen fall wegschmeißen
daraus mache ich gleich noch eine
gemüsebrühe und hier habe ich jetzt
praktisch mein catcher was noch
eingekocht werden muss also kommen sie
wieder zurück in den topf und dann lass
ich es nochmal schön aufkochen und
wirklich dick einkochen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal gläser
vorbereiten in dies beim einfüllen werde
beide sorten ketchup sannitz eingekocht
an dieser stelle dürft ihr auch gerne
noch nachwürzen
probiert es einfach mal ich muss jetzt
hier garnicht nachwürzen
und ich muss sagen dass beide fast
idente schmecken die apfel variante
schmeckt mir richtig gut die hier auch
aber ich weiß ja das sind der april
variante kein zugesetzter zucker drin
ist deswegen würde ich glaube ich immer
wieder die aquarien kochen von der
konsistenz her ist sie ein bisschen
anders weil sie einfach durch den apfel
so ein bisschen breiter wird finde ich
aber gar nicht schlimm
hier sieht man beide nochmal im
vergleich und man keiner die ohne apfel
sozusagen bisschen länger einkochen
lassen und die mit apfel muss gar nicht
so lange kochen
ich finde jetzt beide ketchup sorten in
verschiedene gläser ein und habe jetzt
die gläser bereits ausgewaschenen ganz
heiß ihr könnt sie auch abkochen so sind
sie auch wirklich ganz sauber und die
ganze bakterien sind weg
pro ketchup sorte habe ich jetzt hier
jeweils 300 gramm ketchup rausbekommen
also echt richtig gut das dunklere hier
ist das ketchup mit zucker und das
hellere ist das ketchup mit apfel und
den rest habe ich jetzt hier noch
eingefüllt wird alles noch vakuum ihren
und einfach in dampf backofen dann
steril machen und die reste hier bitte
gar nicht wegschmeißen
ich zeige euch nämlich gleich was sie
noch aus den resten mache wird jetzt
aber zuerst noch eine tomatensoße
zubereiten denn tomatensoße aus dem ofen
die es wirklich super lecker
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach die tomaten
große tomaten kleine tomaten ganz egal
hauptsache sie sind drive die großen
werde ich so ein bisschen halbieren oder
sogar viertel die kleinen könnt ihr im
ganzen einfach ins blech schmeißen und
vor allem gelbe tomaten schmecken hier
wirklich wunderbar
und noch ein bisschen rosmarin der passt
immer gut in der tomatensoße rosmarin
der rosmarin den habe ich jetzt bereits
gewaschen
da kommt direkt mit hier ein genauso wie
die knoblauchzehen und etwas olivenöl
etwas zucker kommt noch dran zum
karamellisieren und jetzt einfach alles
schön verbinden und dann wird es jetzt
hier schön im ofen gerüstet in der
zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal zwiebel
klein schneiden und mit olivenöl in
einem topf und glasig anbraten
das wird becker
zwiebeln wir sind jetzt richtig schön
angebraten und die tomaten im ofen sind
jetzt auch fertig lecker
guckt euch das mal an so sehen sie
wirklich perfekt aus und fliegt hier in
der küche richtig lecker jetzt lasse ich
also die zwiebeln mit den tomaten hier
ab im prinzip kann man da auch jetzt
direkt bei getränken und das schon
lecker
ihr könnt auch wirklich ne 3 45 fache
menge direkt zu bereiten so viele
tomaten wie ihr eben da habt groß marin
nehme ich jetzt schon mal raus er hat
seinen dienst getan
und dafür gebe ich jetzt hier etwas
oregano rein
die zunahme ist auf den garten
das dürfte reichen jetzt kann ich hier
die soße nochmals aufkochen lassen und
würde dann einfach mit salz und pfeffer
und werde anschließend dann durch ein
feines sieb passieren
wenn die sauce ein mal aufgekocht ist
und hier sie geburts habt einfach einmal
kurz durch pürieren und dann durch das
fleißige lieschen wieder durch streichen
so sind die stückchen weg die mögen
samir und ella sowieso nicht so gerne
und aus dem rest mache ich dann auch mit
gemüsebrühe und die soße die ist echt
super einfach wir gehen auch gerne mal
spontan in den garten wenn wir ganz
viele tomaten haben halte ich sehe den
backofen und dann geht der rest echt
super einfach vor allem steht man nicht
ewig am herd denn der backofen macht ihr
die meiste arbeit
so hier ist jetzt meine tomatensoße ich
habe übrigens noch mal im nachgang ein
paar tomaten gerüstet damit ich einfach
ganz viel tomatensoße habe die dürft ihr
jetzt an der stelle nochmals abschmecken
ich habe das schon getan und sie
schmeckt wunderbar ich brauche gar
nichts mehr kein salz pfeffer alles
perfekt und ich schreibe euch einfach
die genauen mengen bei mir ins rezept
und jetzt lasse ich sie hier noch einmal
aufkochen und füllte dann in
ausgewaschenen gläser und wechseln auch
ein wacom ihren und den rest den ich
jetzt hier habe das jetzt echt viel den
schmeiße ich auf keinen fall weg da wird
nämlich noch gedauert daraus mache ich
dann nämlich eine gemüsebrühe und so
habt ihr wirklich das komplette gemüse
aufgebraucht und alles schön verwertet
und habe nichts was ihr wachsen wird
kommen sie hier noch bei 100 grad in den
dampf backofen und dann kann nichts mehr
schief gehen dann sind sie wirklich
lange haltbar 100 grad
die reste können sie dann ganz einfach
im der automaten oder zum beispiel im
backofen trocknen bei heißluft ich
trockne sie jetzt im der automaten
ich streiche jetzt einfach ganz dünn auf
silikon matten backpapier geht auch und
dann werden sie getrocknet und nach dem
trocknen ganz einfach im mixer fein
gemahlen und dann habe ich mein eigenes
gewürz pulver also die gemüsebrühe und
damit könnt ihr dann alles würzen und
dieser gemüsebrühe passt ich hätte jetzt
etwa der backofen trocknen bei heißluft
auch auf mehreren ebenen oder wie gesagt
hier irgend der automaten das mache ich
jetzt hier im backofen solltet ihr
einfach ab und zu mal die backofentür
öffnen damit die feuchtigkeit auch
entweichen kann
das entfällt hier beim der automaten 45
und der automat der spielt auch die
hauptrolle für die nächste tomaten
verwertungs idee denn ich mache jetzt
noch getrocknete bzw gibt dörte tomaten
die könnt ihr im der automat machen oder
im heißluftballon
jetzt habe ich jetzt schon hergestellten
der tomatensauce habe ich schon
hergestellt jetzt kommt die dritte
variante gedachte tomaten
ich finde getrocknete tomaten richtig
lecker ihr könnt entweder im backofen
machen an der sonne oder in einem der
automaten an der sonne ist bei uns ein
bisschen schlecht denn so viele
sonnenstunden gibt es gerade nicht mehr
am automaten ist es wirklich super
praktisch der entzieht nämlich den
tomaten die komplette flüssigkeit und
das ganze bei niedriger temperatur so
dass die vitamine eben auch erhalten
bleiben
ich habe jetzt hier die cocktailtomaten
ausgewählt und habe sie schon halbiert
dies als ich jetzt ungefähr in ein
bisschen pfeffer 1 werferin 7 und salzen
sie jetzt ist es ein
das ist jetzt auch das erste mal dass
ich tomaten aus unserem eigenen garten
deswegen ist es heute eine premiere und
die habe ich diese kleinen backbleche
oder der bleche und aufs und das da habe
ich jetzt die silikon matte gelegt das
war hier einfach mit dabei damit der
automatischen sauber bleibt die tomaten
wirklich jetzt mit der schnittfläche
nach oben hier drauf nicht zu dicht denn
die luft soll ja auch wirklich schön gut
zirkulieren können
[Musik]
das blech mit dem silikon lege ich jetzt
erstmal hier ganz unten rein damit falls
etwas drop das alles hier drauf tropfen
nicht in die maschine
ich kann hier bis zu sechs bleche
reinschieben aber ich habe jetzt nur
drei das passt auch ganz gut und dann
verschließe ich die tür stellte
automaten auf 50 grad und dann dauert es
so zwischen sechs bis zehn stunden je
nachdem wie groß die tomaten sind
ich stelle jetzt erstmal auf acht
stunden ein schauder morgen früh noch
mal rein und dann machen wir die
getrockneten tomaten noch haltbar
[Musik]
die gedämmten tomaten sind teilweise
richtig gut durchgetrocknet so ein
bisschen restfeuchtigkeit nicht immer
daher empfiehlt es sich die getrockneten
tomaten dann nochmal dem olivenöl
einzulegen
das hat den vorteil dass dann keine luft
dran kommt das kann sich kein schimmel
bilden und sind dadurch länger haltbar
und außerdem stellt man damit auch sein
eigenes kräuteröl herren denn das öl von
den getrockneten tomaten das ist dann
wirklich richtig automatisch ich habe
jetzt hier drei gläser die habe ich
bereits stabilisiert im dampf backofen
da kommen jetzt die tomaten und hier
könnt ihr jetzt wenn ihr möchtet noch
gewürze dazugeben knoblauch pfeffer
ich gebe ihnen ein glas sogar noch eine
chili mit rein die ich aus im garten
habe und getrocknet habe das ist dann
mein gläschen dann gebe ich noch etwas
pfeffer mit rein und ein bisschen
knoblauch das ist jetzt echt große
knoblauchzehen und ich werde jetzt
gleich noch vakuum ihren und durch das
vakuum wird einfach der geschmack noch
intensiver das heißt ich nehme jetzt
wirklich nur ganz wenige kräuter und
gewürze und dann kann man das wirklich
mehrere wochen stehen lassen schön
durchziehen lassen und hat ein schönes
würziges öl und eben um die tomaten
[Musik]
und so könnte es jetzt verschlossen im
kühlschrank gehört haben oder einfach
einfach kommen so sind sie noch länger
haltbar
die getrocknete gemüsebrühe die kommt
dann in den mixer wird zerkleinert und
kann dann abgefüllt werden
und dieser wirklich jetzt super trocken
das heißt die gemüsebrühe die ist echt
ewig haltbar so jetzt habe ich hier
alles verbraucht alle tomaten
aufgebraucht und haltbar gemacht woran
sie mir doch probieren ja ich würde
jetzt mal sagen also die gemüsebrühe
die könnt ihr entweder zum würzen nehmen
von suppen soßen von essen oder einfach
mit heißem wasser aufgießen und wirklich
als pure gemüsebrühe als tomaten brühe
mit paar nudeln oder so gries locker
erreicht einfach mit zur krise lokal
essen
ich habe ich ja die getrockneten tomaten
in öl struktur das sind auch mega kult
vor allem weil es kleine guck dir das
war etwas vom öl genau olivenöl maximal
probieren und eigentlich lässt du dir
ein paar tage stehen und dann aber ich
hab's vakuumiert und durchs vakuum durch
diesen druck sieht praktisch das gewiss
schon ein
tomaten sauce okay wir haben ein
bisschen etiketten gebastelt wir haben
unsere eigene anzeige bekommen hier
verkaufte ja trotzdem leuten uns auch
bei den jerry's angeschrieben und jetzt
ganz cool ich also wenn es jetzt ben
jerry's sie ganz ganz lieben gruß ist
und wir haben dann werden die ice
nachgemacht könnte man hier segeln muss
man ja und das ist jetzt fragt sich eine
fertige tomatensoße
das heißt wenn du hunger hast oder der
papa oder wir einfach nudeln abkochen
mit der tomatensauce essen und hier habe
ich noch ketchup und zwar einmal ohne
zucker und einmal mit zucker also ganz
original und das ketchup ohne zucker
wird mit apfel gemacht ok und ihr dürft
es mal probieren und ich meine es sieht
jetzt ganz natürlich aus das heißt nicht
wie radicova ab weil das fertige ketchup
ist viel kampf viel roter muss ich sagen
aber oftmals werden auch gefärbt nicht
beides nicht welches mit oder ohne zum
ja stimmen weil das ein geländer
etiketten drauf
in internaten sitzen kann er nicht dazu
machen dann wird man dich in was für
mich einen landes tomaten im super und
ich kann jetzt schon sagen dass es mit
apfel
ich merke es klar wenn du mal gesagt
hast du hast 1 gemacht dann lieber
gleich 40 oder im einsatz wobei ich da
so dass witze gemacht der bücherkiste
kilo weniger
das schmeckt halt finde ich original wie
ketchup
das ist halt so mega sich ja ich weiß
nicht welcher warum wir sind ketchup gar
nicht mehr gewohnt
wir haben es irgendwie will es ist echt
so wie vielleicht ganz ganz selten also
die samira macht sowieso noch nie
ketchup so richtig die ella ist da eher
skeptisch
aber wer kaufen zu halten hat weil ich
find's einfach das ist voll die
zuckerfabrik es für uns immer ganz
ehrlich jetzt mal wenn du bist und nur
um ist mit ketchup jan o also es geht
immer also auch mich kein
heckenwirtschaft leute und es gibt ja
auch richtig coole jobs ordnung wenn
dann finde ich muss man schon marken
holen die sind schon da kann sich aber
gut
eigentlich nicht aber des guten und ich
finde die mit dem apfel echt mega die
andere auf und die sind alle gleich die
sind alle gleich genau und tomatensoße
die hatte die letzte woche okay das ist
auch nicht barilla erzeugen barilla
nichts gegen euch bald nur also keine
anzeigen ausschicken genau also jetzt
habt ihr hier ideen wie ihr eure tomaten
aus dem garten oder eure gekauft und
tomaten verwerten und haltbar machen
könnt probiert gerne die rezepte aus
postet sie mit diesem herr staeck und
dann sehe ich eure nachgemachten sache
nämlich auch gerne keine möglichkeit
noch das ist auch cool zu verschenken
für mainz machen er vielleicht in der
app vielleicht diesen ausschnitten dass
die leute ist ausdrucken können können
wir gleich machen ja das können wir
machen es möglich
wenn keines tomatenketchup nichts denken
also die heizkosten caterings dagegen
haben würden wir gerne dass bei uns eine
rein machen
ein bisschen das war doch klären ok
alles klar also viel spaß beim
nachmachen man bis zum nächsten mal
ich glaube ich mache noch ein video über
chilis wollt ihr ein video über schilys
wie man chilis einkocht haltbar macht
tabasco kochen oder so dann schreibt es
gerne in die kommentare